this is a reference sheet as you can see
my phone actually yeah right there so I
was gonna say breakfast and coffee today
you know that's where it says these are
all of the things which we like look we
know to my heart remember all of these
get handed these fewer examines I
printed a tune exactement full Mitchell
Guetta except um Vanessa is slightly
less cheap on paper so you'll get this
is just real quickly turn to the very
back some people looking at your minds a
graduated whitening because this is not
just this is a halfway down the second
column you should see section it's
called probability and underneath that
is always between notation you like
Buddhism path is the stuff we've just
been looking at its said notation okay
so watching a highlight where it says
probability and up before we unpack
let's go Mookie I do my same I encourage
all of you as we go through this the
reason I want you to keep this is you
shoot me son eventually take you on as
you like okay because if you are going
to use this in your right hands if
you're going to use this in your exam
you need to know when things there are
going to be some students who feel like
I know a bunch of these these well
enough that I never have to look at this
reference for example what is that it
doesn't tell me you but hopefully you
recognize it from probably years ago and
though it is a equals P what is it what
is that what's a traveler gap gives you
included a heading formula is this say
it's right who died one interest its
compound interest thank you very much so
this is the only machine before it's
there just in case you forget it but I
hope by the time we get into view 12 you
guys like I don't need to look it up
okay
however come back to the inside like
there's lots of stumpy which is designed
because but don't spend time in the exam
looking at hunting down for these okay
you don't have that time but I'm
highlighting for you now okay now you
will do with the probability studies
what it means
okay so you got highlighted in your
booklets write down the stuff there
because there's not really enough space
on the reference sheets you have all the
private notes for everything it's going
to come very crowded very fast so in
your boots will have enough space
between surfaces you can see that the
presentation we use is people so how
would you read that survey so could be
if you had a Venn diagram right so it's
like this is something that's a be
enough fun or rainy or winning the
lottery right and some event baby right
and what we want is what's the positive
photos of them happy together that's
what that you say
and somebody who had the way and okay so
what happens after that what was they
actually right it's the probability of
what hey
and it's not written there I'm gonna ask
you to write it down in your books right
there's a there's an operation hiding
between the two things that's kind of
implied ones that they apply the
operation it's multiplication now I want
us to write that down because it's an
important distinction you know might
sometimes we add priorities sometimes we
add probabilities but not what you want
both of these events to happen
simultaneously at the same time right so
if you want the probability of anything
together right what do you do
so for instance if you wanted to roll
the dice and flip a coin and I wanted to
know the probability of rolling a six
and also getting a head right looking
ahead right what's the problem that
you're going to be well what's the
probability of rolling the seat just
what it is and the probability of heads
that's gonna be two so clearly you can
take whatever C's x where you get your
hands up 1 over 12 so just looking at
these notation with you guys do we see
any way before tree diagrams we had the
probabilities written along them so this
is formalizing we've already done so
even though it looks really technical
already been doing this quite happily it
just helps sometimes when you've got the
language annotation to say in my vision
where rather than using lots of words as
you can see it's just much more
efficient okay but you okay with that
first slide on the reference sheet yeah
it could be one for the second one what
does it saying this should really really
look familiar
right like in fact you almost have
exactly this almost all support it says
the probability off and then how do you
read that when you see a 2 a 4 right I'm
interested in either than having write a
for me and then there's my goodness
there's a mess there but does look
familiar does it look like anything
you've already written have a look like
a page right there's a book a heck of a
lot like this it's that same idea right
it's like if you all are here to have
one or the other right
you take one there you go we can add
them because they can happen separately
they don't happen have you have to
happen to get up because it's life and
it's four so you add them but if you
take these two probabilities what you've
done is you have double counted and you
see with double you can see you
actually you have to remove when you've
got both of them because you can't that
twice so you can see the probability of
a intersection does that make sense
um real quick just certain again you you
ground this is something a culprit right
remember I told you about rolling the
die including the point just underneath
you before we do the last affair that
last one right
suppose we represented this on an array
okay so if I wasn't to do for the
employer one of the two options that I
could happen enrolling about one two
three four five six
okay so when we think that this guy here
right to everyone our solution was it
was one hour two for looking ahead
multiplied by one of us seeks for sorry
fantasies we're rolling the six does
that make sense so we've been saying one
option out of 12
I think this what if I said rolling is
cease or flipping ahead he's so what's
the probability then it's six out of 12
so that's and then I would say that's a
probability big that's probability of
flipping and sorry I said rolling around
that's rolling to be ahead and then
rolling it seeks now what suppose told
me this before
so whatever sinks right one happen seeks
because it's 2 out of 12 to agree with
that
look what I've got in there and orange
should you see that see what I've got
there in orange do you see how I double
counted back in my green you got
accounts at once in the road and ones in
because that's why you have to subtract
right and we get 12 can someone go ahead
calculate that I don't have to see
get out I asked you to do that go ahead
chuck it in and let's see if that
matches what your intuition with a
safety work this out just threw it away
pretty careful wait 7 / 12 have a look
at the diagram attending this course it
makes sense once we complete one 5 6 7
out of 12 center space see how this
situation of course you could just
looked at the diagram rather doing that
calculation but we're giving you a much
more complicated situation where the
diagrams are simple you can see how this
is really gonna rescue you
well a little bump down there on the
bottom I'm going to serve you you can
bite down and we'll come back to it this
vertical line here this vertical line
it's about conditions right so it's like
what will happen what's the probability
of getting something so long as you have
some other condition that's being filled
like I said we'll come into this a
little more there this isn't thing I
really want to focus on because the
segmentation which was just having that
what this indicate well tell me a lot of
time leads probability of a and B this
is what we just looked at before right
so you have to multiply those two
together and then what you're going to
divide by years they're probably just
this event because it's shorthand what
we're talking about here this B is the
condition that you know so it changes
your sample space it makes it smaller
like I said we were looking
more detail about that later but this is
so you know why we're doing set notation
you could say this in words are just
some more long and inefficient